there are a lot of hilarious ways that
people try to fake clout and it never
quite works but it's always funny to see
but I'm going to show you guys an
amazing one today we've seen in the past
people creating fake Harvard speeches to
look like they're more important than
they are recently John crostini was
exposed as having a Marvel character in
his list of success stories hundreds of
people all over the world are making
their dreams come true and it's really
exciting seeing the success I know every
one of these faces which I find that
would pretty ballsy by the way because
it's in his webinar but perhaps most
shameless and ingenious of all is the
hustle we're gonna cover today which is
a cammeo hustle I heard about a website
called cameo they'll make videos for
people it's called cameos there's a
bunch of different celebrities on there
and to learn about this we are gonna be
featuring none other than the Cameo King
Wesley billion-dollar and virgin if you
got a 9 to 5 job right now you're cool
hey this is Wesley billion-dollar virgin
I know you're looking at advertising
right now but check it out stop looking
at the car and pay attention to me now
back to me now back at your man now back
to me sadly he isn't me but if he
stopped using ladies scented body wash
and switched to Old Spice he could smell
like he's me now Wes they want you to
believe that he's an incredibly
successful guy and to do this he shows
you how many important people support
him love him and her shouting him out I
Wesley virgin this is a shout-out to
hiatus asana ANCA this is a big
shout-out to my friend besides her girl
Cynthia Bailey from the Real Housewives
of Atlanta and I want to give a huge
shout out to Wesley billion-dollar
virgin that's right he's got some be
list celebrities and the Real Housewives
of Atlanta but he also has some heavy
hitters come in like mr. wonderful
himself in Grant Cardone Leslie keep up
the great work and keep helping people
yo yeah Wesley I'm gonna give you a big
shout out player while it may seem
initially like a mystery why all these
people are are shouting out a relatively
unknown internet marketer it suddenly
becomes clear what's going on when you
start to realize that all of these
people that I'm showing you have one
thing in common
hi I'm Bethenny Frankel and I'm so
excited to be on cameo hi this is Ana
Inca you can find me here on come here
mmm
let's love you want me just the holidays
you shout you out shout out your
business whatever whatever it is you
want I'm going to get a people like hey
if there's somebody out there that
you're thinking about a special person
maybe maybe a son a nephew
billion-dollar burger yes they're all
featured on cameo I mean think about how
crazy this is
this guy is hiring out cameos to make
himself look like he's known by all
these people posting it and going look
at who shouted me out just cuz I'm such
a great guy he paid for it hey yo yo
Wesley I want to give you a big shout
out player you know in high school when
like somebody would fake having a
girlfriend that was from another school
this is like kind of that it's like
paying someone to go to prom with you or
something like that so you can seem
cooler than you are it's so shameless
that it's almost beautiful in a certain
kind of way and you know I'm not one to
hate on the hustle
which is why rather than just dunking on
this guy all day we could spend another
five minutes on it instead I wanted to
help you out Wesley because I know times
are tough maybe those sales pages aren't
converting as well as they used to so I
got you a second cameo from one of my
favorite cameos of yours ananka she
shouted you out before but I told her
that uh you needed a little pick-me-up
from your seafood from from the guy that
you learned everything from okay so Wes
this is for you Casilla asked me to tell
you to listen up
stay on the grind and don't forget to
smash like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]